I had no sound down forgot the sound
okay now let me start over
hello everyone I was gonna do a
different subject this week but I
decided to change the subject because I
had a discussion this week on an
extinction and it was quite elaborate
and I thought it was worth discussing in
here in this in this on this channel in
this forum and I had a I put up a little
article a little get a little picture
really it looks like this I'll put it up
there and it says please do not confuse
me with guy McPherson he is a concern
conservationist a climate change
an individual who has no clue whatsoever
about extinction
it is idiots who believe that humans
will go extinct because of the
environment or pollution or because we
are too many the dinos then disappear
because the climate change are because
an asteroid struck the earth or because
of pollution they went extinct like
humans will go extinct starvation it is
when food runs out that mass starvation
I posted that in our Facebook forum
there the irrational science scientific
method and ok you don't have to agree
with me and I know a lot of people out
there who watch me don't agree with me
on extinction and where a guy McPherson
agrees with me is that we're soon going
to become extinct what is the difference
the difference is that he is that's
that's religion I want to make that's
got to be clarified because you know one
thing is the theory that you explained
the mechanism how humans or any animal
for that matter goes extinct that's one
issue that's a scientific issue the
religion part is when someone says well
when is it going to have them saying a
dog will starve if you don't give and
that's the point here you can say for
example that you know that if the dog
doesn't eat he will go extinct but when
is that gonna happen gonna happen
two o'clock four o'clock ten o'clock we
don't know he might last a little less a
little longer okay but when you say soon
like ballpark
again I'd rather not even give I'm a
terrible astrologer okay I'm a terrible
astrologer humans will always think
humans will go extinct soon whatever the
word soon goes it means to you and of
course the young people say well I don't
want it to go to happen so soon because
I'm still alive I want to live my life I
want to retire and then it can happen
after
me and that's soon enough and that's
fine everybody has his own word his own
definition for soon okay I think it's
gonna happen sooner but again I'm a
lousy astrologer I'm more interested in
the mechanisms and that's what I'd like
to discuss today because people confuse
me with guy McPherson then they say oh
you said the same thing as guy McPherson
and I don't and I want to make sure that
people understand that and for this you
need to understand the contrast you got
to see the differences between what he
says and what I'm saying okay so it
turns out that guy came on the line and
we had a little tit attack there a
little back-and-forth and he was
represented most of the time by another
fellow I guess he's his pinch-hitter or
whatever you know came out there and
told me a lot about guy and he wrote
most of the comments in the name of guy
McPherson but I want to focus on on
these things because for me they're very
important in the sense that you know a
lot of these conservationists
environmentalists they are lobbyists my
big problem with that is that if they
say like guy says that were definitely
going extinct while I lobby anybody why
do anything I mean if it's guaranteed if
extinction is guaranteed we shouldn't be
bothering the politicians they've got
enough on their hands why would you
bother a politician to change the
politics so that you got clean air or
whatever you want to reverse
industrialization whatever you want to
do out there why do that if if get if
extinction is guaranteed because it
isn't I think what they're saying is no
they're saying that is no just again if
they're lobbying and everything they're
samung the way I think everyone
understands environmentalist is unless
we don't change our ways then it's a
guaranteed that's we know that's 99% of
these folks but it's as I understand it
it's not guy McPherson okay guy
McPherson says no
what we're going extinct oh it's a
matter of time then yeah he said in fact
he gives us two years to live two years
that's yeah and again I think he's
making the same error I made when I made
my predictions I think he's a lousy
astrologer I'm a lousy astrologer as
well we should not confuse the dates
that he gives with a mechanism I'm gonna
talk about the mechanism I don't care
about the dates the dates are you know
opinions you know they may happen they
may not but we're talking about a
mechanism what is what's gonna kill
humans that's what we're discussing here
and and I think this is because there's
too many variables to pinpoint the date
yeah that's one of the issue the other
issue is that you know most people don't
really believe that humans going extinct
they can't visualize it they can't see
it they think it's just an issue of the
boy who cried wolf you know or whatever
you know people don't really think that
eight billion people can suddenly die
and by suddenly I mean geologically
suddenly like in a matter of weeks and
that's what guy apparently believes and
for sure I believe that's gonna happen
as well but we believe this for
different reasons the causes the
mechanisms okay so guy was represented
by a name by a began by a name of
Jackson Davis and Davis says the
following about guy okay as a
conservative conservation biologist he
is knowledgeable in three areas
speciation how new species come into
existence habitat what are the
conditions necessary for a species to
continue living and extinction what
changes in conditions will result in
extinction okay so apparently guy
presents himself an expert in the word
in the one that I'm interested in
extinction and I'm saying he's not an
extinction expert and the first
objection I have against that why I
believe that is that you know you don't
see any
mention of past species you know you
don't see him talking about how how
species in the Permian died how specie
and Triassic died how the dinosaurs of
the Cretaceous died he doesn't speak
about any of that he just talks about
man he talks about the future not about
the past and you know I don't I I don't
like that because you know my many of
you know that you know the way I look at
things is that science is about
explaining the past consummated events
and in the case of extinction
you get explained first past extinctions
and I've got that problem with a lot of
people out there who I talked to because
you know I want to make sure that we
understand first how how consummated
events happen let alone non consummate
events like you know the extinction of
humans well I think it's because you're
the only one that's actually using a an
extinction method that happened in the
past you're extrapolating that to us
yeah instead of saying how the dinosaurs
died is one way the way we're gonna die
in a different way through robots or
some crazy stuff that we brought on
ourselves you're the only one that's
using the same cookie cutter for the
past and the present that's where these
people can really say well you know
environmentalism killed the dinosaurs
because they used too much aerosol but
see I think you do need to have an idea
if you're gonna talk about extinction
you got to start you know how past the
species it became extinct why would we
belong to the animal kingdom and why
would be died in a different way than
the rest of the animals died because we
live so differently yeah but but see
this is the argument that I have the
underlying argument is that the fact
that we are smart that we are
intelligent the fact that we can force
events the fact that we have technology
has no bearing on the mechanism of
extinction because if it did we would
come extinct I mean if if there is a
technology that we can invent to solve
some kind of problem out there among
them environmental problems chemical
problems pollution problems if we could
clear the air does that mean we live
forever you know if we can avoid the
melting of the ice caps I don't put
refrigerators in the North Pole whatever
technology we in fact right does that
mean we can forestall the extinction say
oh look we we found that there was this
problem methane or whatever coming out
and we or anoxia or whatever and we were
able to deal with it chemically by
throwing I don't know what what chemical
in the air and we solved it the ozone
layer is disappearing we throw more
oxygen here we create chemically create
massive amounts of ozone you know
massive engineer a massive engineering
scale that means we avoid extinction and
what I'm saying is extinction is
guaranteed for all animals and with that
I include the humans within the animal
kingdom and I'm saying that just like
all other animals the fact that we are
intelligent the fact that we have
technology we can force events and react
in advance has no bearing on the
mechanism of extinction and and that's
if I can produce a foolproof mechanism
then that's the one that's going to kill
man that's the one that killed all the
animals because they could avoid it
either if we are smart have technology
we can't avoid it certainly no other
animal could either and so what I'm
saying is I can explain the extinctions
of the past based on what I need what I
can project for humans and I'm saying if
there if I can produce a mechanism that
humans cannot fix cannot solve a
technology or whatever for sure that's
the mechanism that killed all the other
animals because they could avoid it
either
that's my reasoning that's why I'm
saying that you do need absolutely to
understand how extinctions happened in
the past okay this guy continues his
name is Jackson Davis and he says he
just gives a little more bio on
guy Macpherson he says most of his
research had to do with the rate with
range science that is and keep in mind
what's what he's saying here right that
is under what conditions will the crops
that humans and other animals eat be
able to survive
it was while editing a book in 2002 that
he realized that as the climate became
hotter those crops would not be able to
survive and mass starvation would be the
result but by 2007 he thought that
global warming could be stopped if there
was a collapse of industrial
civilization
glower army stopped if there's a
collapse of industrial civilization
listen to that however in 2010 he read a
paper on global dimming and realized
that if industrial civilization would
collapse the warming would occur much
faster even faster in other words he's
not concerned about mass starvation he's
saying there's mass starvation but
obviously a lot of people were survived
in that so-called mass starvation he's
not saying mass starvation ends in
extinction he's saying it kills lots of
people it destroys industrial
civilization which is what all
environmentalist want and he said but
unfortunately that the warming would
occur even faster now he has relied on
recent climate science to indicate that
abrupt nature of climate changes take
taking place and this has led him to his
current outlook and he has relied on
Arctic scientists to establish the
danger posed by the warming of the sea
beds in the shallow Arctic seas in terms
of the release of gigatons of methane
stored in the form of frozen methane
clathrates
his claims are all based on
peer-reviewed science is he saying that
the starvation kills a lot of people
most people yeah the remaining people
would throw even more trash in the air
no he's saying that apparently the the
collapse of industrial civilization
which all environmentalists and
conservationists pray to every day he
says that's going to be good the fact
that that collapses and all the rich you
know get thrown into trashcan all the
Communists take over the planet or
whatever we're all the equal finding and
we all rely on natural economy and etc
etc so whoever survives that industrial
collapse we're still going to have all
this gases that we've created I guess
and that's gonna continue melting the
ice caps somehow and and I guess that
pollution is eventually gonna kill us
either the the the overflowing of the
oceans or the pollution that we already
threw up there I don't know I don't know
what they have over their mind because I
don't care to even listen to any of that
it's nice you know I'll tell you why a
lot of this comes from you know all
these environmentalist paleontologists
who are looking at past extinctions and
they're coming up with these same
theories so it's not like guy invented
this theory he came up with all these
theories from all these other guys and
I'll go over that in a minute
but let's continue here okay so the main
point I want to say is that you know he
thinks he's an expert in extinction guy
McPherson he came in later on and
contributed a couple posts couple
comments on what this Jackson Davis
fellow said and one of the things that
came out of this that they say this was
said by Jackson Davis the collapse of
industrial civilization and a result of
mass starvation is specifically
mentioned in the outlook as well as in
the presentation so you would think that
they're referring to some kind of
economic meltdown right but then he adds
I have heard predictions of another
collapse of the money system for the
last ten years and it is as yet to
happen in other words these people don't
believe that there's gonna be a collapse
of the money system the
the artificial economy that humans have
now I'm not saying that you should
believe it huh all I'm saying is all I'm
saying is that's what I'm saying um my
my proposal is that the economic system
is going to collapse that's not what
these people are saying these people are
saying something else they're saying
look there's all this stuff going on in
here all this and atmosphere all this
heat temperature whatever
there's melting of the ice caps that's
gonna cause the destruction of all of
the crops that's going to cause mass
starvation and the mass starvation is
gonna trigger
the collapse of civilization as we know
it a new civilization develops but it
won't be able to survive because I guess
we did already too much damage to the
environment and you know we released too
much garbage in the air so so I wanted
to understand them that there's a
difference between what they say and
what I say I'm saying something totally
different I'm saying this is a
completely 100 percent 120 percent an
economic issue the money supply the
money is gonna be no more money's gonna
disappear money will have no value
people will not be able to trade I don't
I don't want you to say that you agree
with me I just want you to understand
what I'm proposing and how many times
yeah I'm gonna say bigger yeah but no
I'm paranoid because people don't
understand what I'm saying I'm saying
money's gonna disappear that's different
what these people are saying they feel
we're talking about temperature and
climate and environmental things they
don't they don't even touch the word
money they just say in general terms a
blanket statement they're saying
industrial civilization civilization is
gonna collapse
whatever that means it's like it's gonna
collapse and may get rid of the problem
they say and they focus on temperature
and pollution and whatever and and for
some reason I can't get people to notice
that I'm saying something totally
different they think I'm saying the same
thing oh yeah he mentioned the word
starvation also yeah he mentioned the
word starvation but it's not starvation
is gonna kill us he's saying that's
gonna be gases in the environment the
heat
the floods saying that the starvation
will make me environmentalism worse yeah
that's all you say
like the starvation is just a catalyst
for the environmental collapse it's not
the something starvation collapse is the
environmental collapse
brought on by or triggers triggered by
starvation yeah and you know and so I
just I don't know how else to say it
because people keep confusing me with
people like guy McPherson I'll go in in
a second let me let me finish with this
because I really want to get this you
know I want people to understand that
I'm in a different boat altogether okay
so by any means I'm against the
environmental is I'm against
climatologist climate changes I'm
against environmentalists and what is it
yes it's got nothing to do with anything
I'd say the environment has nothing to
do with anything now this is one of the
things that got McPherson answered to me
he says Bill Katie doesn't use evidence
and he's not read the abundant evidence
I've compiled color me shocked I don't
have evidence and hopefully I'll never
have evidence I I answered to him that
you know I'm evidence is what is used to
persuade convince convert and recruit if
you're gonna recruit someone then you
try to bring the Bible and show them you
know all the evidence in the Bible and
try to persuade them to believe you and
that's what these people are doing
they're saying look we have the evidence
so what do you have evidence if it's got
nothing to do with anything I don't I
don't give a damn if you got everything
better said that evidence is subjective
or what what what you interpret out of
it from what you could be evidence for
another guy could be yeah the Bible you
know some people say that the perfection
of a flower proves God that's evidence
for him and the other guy says you know
it just proves that there's was
evolution and that's how that flower
came to be and and you know who do you
believe yeah are you you know whichever
you believe it's just your belief you
might accept that it's God that made it
that way with
and you know petal by petal or you can
believe the other guy who says you know
this was a long process of evolution
that for this plant okay that's kind of
a scarecrow
argument in a sense that you have to
contend with the fact that you are using
some form of facts or patterns when
you're talking about extinction I mean
when you follow a logical sequence yeah
but they're using kind of things that
happen or things that could happen
things we know to happen so you're still
using some quasi evidence yeah the point
here is that you know you don't harp on
the evidence in other words I don't say
look you got to believe me because look
I've got evidence that's not the issue
the issue is look the only purpose of
the evidence is to show to explain a
mechanism of why you're justified in
your mechanism not why you know not
because you're trying to convince the
other guy but you're trying to say look
there's there's and I'm gonna show a
couple evidence right now idea does this
mechanism make sense yeah essentially
that's that's is no more you the
evidence is used for the mechanism to
understand the mechanisms not to
persuade you that look I've got evidence
you must believe in what I'm saying
that's what these guys they I like to
think about it is with assumptions where
evidence and today's beer evidence and
assumptions are more like okay you can
assume anything right and then you make
your theory if the theory makes sense
that's all we care about if you accept
the assumptions is besides the point
right along with whether you accept the
evidence or not let's put that aside for
now assuming something is just okay
let's let's assume this is evidence
right let's assume this is how how we
say it is you know whatever you put in
the Assumption phrase let's just take
that for face value so understand the
mechanism thereafter yeah like how do
the dominoes fall if this is the case
and then what if you if there isn't a
case or not that's it besides the point
the Assumption the starting point but
you kind of you kind of harp on the
mechanism that comes after the
assumptions yeah but that begs the
question what assumptions do you present
for your theory cause he presents
environmental changes in ice cap melting
and for this we we have to look at see I
gotta go through this so that you
understand exactly where he got a lot of
this stuff and why a lot of these
environmentalists have this in their
minds that there's something in
environments gonna kill us
okay and we need to see the whole
picture I want you two to follow this
train of thought because it's really how
how these people come up with all this
stuff and you should really keep it this
in mind and the other thing that you
know he says his bill Gaeta doesn't use
evidence he's not read abundant evidence
I've compiled color me shocked okay so
he agrees that I don't use evidence and
that I don't have evidence and fine
that's that's I hope to keep it that way
so where do they get all these so what
is it step by step picture of how humans
are gonna disappear that's that's what I
wanted to see and fortunately they
answered my question here here are the
step by step so you can take notes now
Oh wrong one sorry you can take notes
now here here's the first one he says
here's the step by step approach first
first step an ice-free Arctic let me
move aside here for a second an ice-free
Arctic Ocean later this year or the next
so this year or next year the ice melts
and we have an ice-free Arctic Ocean
that's the first step what does that
cause it costs a burst into the
atmosphere of 50 Giga tons of methane
from the frozen methane clathrates in
the permafrost lying on the shallow sea
beds of the Arctic Ocean causing the
global average temperatures to rise 1.3
degrees C more in in a very short time
okay so we have two things the melting
of the ice caps and the raising
of the temperature global temperatures
by 1.3 degrees C and that's gonna happen
within a year apparently that's their
calculation okay next step what does
this cause it causes a more than 2
degrees C temperature increase in the
so-called breadbasket regions of the
Northern Hemisphere where most of the
food plants you know food plants are
grown okay so so we have what we have
ice-free Arctic all the Arctic ice melts
rising of the oceans we have a release
of methane clathrates
and and there's a rise in global
temperatures at one point three degrees
this in turn causes a more than one of
two degrees temperature rise in the
breadbasket where we produce most of the
food in the world that's a first step
second step or I guess you can add these
up right second step is wet the effect
of this temperature increase is that
these plants will die and mass
starvation will be the result and I
thought that was the end of it I said
okay so they're kind of getting close to
where I'm at because I'm saying it's
gonna be caused by starvation they're
just saying you know I'm saying this
money is gonna disappear we're not gonna
have any incentive to deliver food to
produce it or deliberate it to the
cities that's what I'm saying
these people are saying no it's gonna be
temperature and global warming or
whatever I'm melting of the ice caps and
they'll kill the plants and mass
starvation will ensue and you say okay
we're done right no we're not because
mass starvation doesn't mean to them
what it means to me for me it means the
last human on earth or maybe there's a
few pockets of humans somewhere on the
planet that still survive and they'll
live out the rest of their lives that's
it for us they're saying something else
they're saying mass starvation means
that out of eight billion people maybe
seven billion will die and 1 billion
survive or a million or a few million
which I doubt
cannot imagine that but these people are
saying lots of people will survive and
what they're saying the masturbation is
jeanna caused the collapse of industrial
civilization and there's a steep
reduction in the burning of fossil fuels
ok
and so guy McPherson thought that this
might be beneficial at first since there
would be a reduction in the emission of
co2 and other so-called greenhouse gases
in other words these guys are thinking
only in terms of gases you know the heat
we relive the pollution we release all
this stuff really he's saying that and
he could have left out the starvation
part yes saying essentially that with
what we've already done whether we all
starve or not whether you bring in the
dying of the plants or not yeah the
pollution we've already done will kill
us in the next no nobody's saying the
starvation he'll kill most of the human
but he could have left that part out if
he says this might be beneficial at
first as there would be a reduction in
the emission of co2 and others so far
yeah but you need to kill the humans to
produce that no because he's saying but
the global average temperature will
continue to rise with him due to the
emissions generator over the last 10 20
years we've already done this yeah yeah
yeah it already done the damage so yeah
yeah okay yeah ok ok because he goes to
the second I think that's because he
goes to the second sub he says but the
global average temperature will continue
to rise due to the emissions generate
over the last one ten to twenty years in
other word he says the global warming
will not stop because industrial
civilization dies well we don't have any
smokestack factories anymore so we don't
throw any more up there but it'll
continue to rise simply because you know
all this gases are already released and
they're doing their damage you know in
the background while we're still breathe
we've already done the damage yeah well
okay here's the last part of it he says
however the reduction in the burning of
fossil fuels will also result in the
reduction of the emissions of aerosol
particulates such as so3 which reflects
solar energy
back into space before it reaches the
earth the so called global dimming
effect these aerosol particulates fall
out of the atmosphere in a matter of
weeks or months and the global average
temperature will rise another three
degrees causing the extinction of
virtually all living beings on earth
this can happen by next spring or the
spring of the following year so be
prepared
I've been forewarned that I better start
shedding my skin because it's gonna be
so hot I won't be able to stand it so so
so these people are saying all I'm
saying here is that these people are
saying something different than me I
want to get that across because people
keep confusing with me with them and I'm
saying can't people understand the
difference environmental is first where
did they get all this nonsense because I
call them idiots yes I use the word it
is because they are idiots they should
be treated as idiots at all time and why
let me tell you where they get all this
nonsense this is all of this comes from
the paleontologists who study past
extinction they how did the animals in
the past die
and so the answer oh we know we can tell
you some kind of environmental
catastrophe caused the extinction of the
animals I'm not gonna talk about the
dinos I'm gonna talk about the most
important extinction of all which is the
one that claimed the most life on earth
and that was the Permian extinction and
that was 252 million years ago or
thereabouts
okay and almost all life died they use
that term they like to use that and they
say almost all life died and so what are
the causes what are people proposing
what are the experts in extinction
proposing for the extinction of the
mammal-like reptiles at the end of the
Permian right before the Triassic where
we had the arcus or a crocodile like
animals what caused it and here here you
see you'll you'll see some of these in
the Wikipedia the first one always is
asteroid it's death by asteroid I call
it okay you kill all the animals some
kind of asteroid impact and here we have
some nice shots and people like these
you know here's here's one I hope you'll
like this one yeah here you have the
asteroid hitting some kind of ocean I
guess you know and it falls and it hits
the earth and everybody likes these
special effects and I guess it was
pretty cool and that's why and that's
why I take this one over over some
background you know this is one of the
reasons these theories are popular
because they you can do a special effect
like this one and people say oh man
that's awesome where's your meteor bows
yeah and as you see the problem with my
with my extinction theory you would have
to wait a few years to watch the entire
movie you know the movie is two years
long I actually like to see that week's
weeks to kill okay but there's movies
that take weeks but they're just cut
they just skip the times they're boring
movies like the road okay just a boy and
his dad trying to get through and it
kind of shows it doesn't show like big
meteors or any of that it's but that's
not saying it could still be cool
without any of these crazy things and I
think they it would be cool to see a
movie that just deals with the
starvation aspect of an extinction
because normally that's like a
background thing in movies like like
effect they don't show it ever you see I
not ever I see all we see the bottle of
coca-cola on the table you know in every
move not everybody everybody's
and in the road they're always famished
and in 28 days later with zombies the
guy gets a sugar crash because all he's
eating is packets from vending machine
okay but he's okay but he gets paid by
sugar so it's like these kind of shows
you know that they're that malnourished
it's mal nourishment not starvation yeah
but we got a problem with that because
he finds packets in the vending machines
and the question is how did the other
guy missed it though the other million
guys they miss that cuz there's only
like ten dudes on earth and there's
probably ten bending machines on earth
we have they always deal with mountain
nourishment or malnutrition but they
never deal with actual starvation
they've had like Kamath cannibals in
movies in in extinction movies but it's
always like a psyche character yeah it's
like an okay it's not the Camerons
account yeah but it's more like a zombie
kind of movie Ryan no Camille I am very
well ready
Book of Eli there's a there's a couple
like this old couple they keeps people
in their basement and eats part eats
pieces of them bit by bit oh that's kind
of like a side character there's they're
not the there is not the norm okay it
starts feet first hopefully because
otherwise sometimes arms or whatever
extremities yeah but it's just like one
scene in the movie it's not like the
whole move because in your movie with
your extinction it would be everyone's
accountable everyone yeah you kill their
next door dated Book of Eli there's kind
of this city like a town or there's like
people walking around doing their normal
stuff and then there's this these
cannibals over here like a side thing
it's not that no so so yeah it's like
wider world what a world at one point
you know if I remember correctly there's
this fort of some kind yeah and and all
this community lives within the fort
they they no longer have all these rich
people you know making billions of
dollars you know Bill Gates and you know
yeah yeah but it's a it's a hierarchy
based on mutual respect and you know
this this world that never us
yeah but the point is that you know he
finds this for in this group of people
that are still alive there you know and
they have food and it's so great my
favorite scene in Waterworld is actually
towards the beginning where the main
characters plucks the last tomato from
his tomato plant and at that point you
go is that his last rations is that like
that's what does he eat fish because
it's what a fisherman I guess a water
rant but they never harp on food yeah
here's another one here's another good
shot you know here's the asteroid this
one this was the chicks a little look
the the one that hit Mexico you know
this is the one that killed the
dinosaurs a allegedly you know and who
doesn't like those special effects I
mean you gotta give it and hand it to
them you know Hollywood does great shows
and people like this stuff and that's
why they believe it because he goes
through the eyes you know people look at
this and say wow you know that's what
happened to the dinosaurs poor poor
animals you know and thank God it came
and all the you know mammals survived
you know which you wonder how you know
and it kind of makes you wonder but the
one I liked the most about the asteroid
hit is this one I love this one because
it shows that the entire earth was
burning it was on fire the entire
surface of the earth is glowing with
fire well because of the asteroid hit
and when it hit all this debris hot
debris - circled the planet as it
whirled and and then started raining on
the poor animal because see you get it
you get to justify how the birds died or
the flying reptiles and not the bird the
birds survived but the flying reptiles
didn't and I guess they were smaller
than a but but what I like about this is
that if you look at this picture right
again flashy scene look the entire plant
is dead so did God create Adam and Eve
again
I mean how did anything survive if the
whole planet is on fire it's heated it's
burning right but this is what they show
you this is what they do but believe it
there's no selectivity here there's no
there's no some died some lived to
evolve onwards it's this looks like
everything's everything has a bug every
right every mother and you know the
problem with this I've got is that they
say that mammals survived
I like it this is the Cretaceous
extinction right and the KT extinction
and and they say mammal sorry you say
well how did the mammal survive and they
say well they divided they they were
able to survive because they detritus
which is the rotting carcasses and [ __ ]
from from dinosaurs and I guess they
survived until God created plants again
you know five six ten twenty years later
so you you wonder how they survived all
this time with a burning planet and they
say you know these people tell you that
they survived under tritter's and and
that's and you know that at that point
that they have no clue whatsoever
what causes extinct well because this is
the main one that's offered not only for
the Cretaceous a lot of people are
suggesting that this is exactly what
happened in the Permian okay but on the
other hand you have the other people on
the other side of the fence and they say
oh no it wasn't an asteroid you're wrong
what we know for sure what happened in
the Permian so what happened in the
Permian well what happened in the
Permian is volcanism okay and here is uh
just a lot one liner we know this is
where guy McPherson got all his ideas
because he follows the environmental as
the environmentalists paleontologists
believes that it was some environmental
catastrophe that suddenly befell all the
animals on earth when you talk about a
meteor hitting
you thought could that still be
considered an environmental yeah because
because the reason its environmental is
that they extrapolate said well that
created tsunamis and and also rained
fire and brimstone from the skies on the
animals so it's not it's not that the
meteor shattered the earth it's more
like the meteor hit the earth and then
that made environmental damage right and
first it killed everyone within a radius
of Ground Zero and then from that point
on you've got all these tsunamis because
if fell in the water it hit could create
grave waves and that killed the animals
on the other side of the planet and then
the the debris that came from the sky
killed the flying reptiles and left the
birds alive I guess and then when they
fell onto the oceans they acidified the
waters and that killed all the the
mosasaurs and left all the fish alive in
the in the sharks you know because
they're still alive so you know they got
all this cell activity with different
mechanisms all based on the asteroids so
there are all environmental catastrophes
but the the authentic catastrophes
catastrophists are people who provide
proposed volcanism and volcanism they
say that the Siberian traps here you see
it Siberian traps eruptions may have
caused dust clouds and acid aerosols
which would have blocked out sunlight
and thus disrupted photosynthesis both
on land and in the fold photic zone of
the ocean causing food chains to
collapse interesting that say causing
food chains to collapse they know the
food chain they know the food chains
collapse but they're they're not saying
they collapse on their own because they
were old or lost genetic diversity they
say no the food chains collapse because
of this you know a greenhouse effect
right Europe yeah and that's essentially
a greenhouse mechanism of a different
sort
it is but if they eventually turn it you
know what's interesting they turn it
into a greenhouse effect because
eventually they say well we went from
hot to cold later on then in cold and
killed whatever survived a hot the heat
then eventually got killed by the cold
yeah so then so they go but that's a
long story okay
but then the eruptions may have also
caused acid rain because you get
explained why you know the animals
underneath the oceans died right and you
got a create acid rain that kills them
selectively like are you saying that you
gotta create yeah and these could not
stand the acid rain the others could you
know you got to have that cell activity
when the aerosol is washed out of the
atmosphere that may have killed land
plants and mollusk and plankton
organisms which had calcium carbonate
shells so it's all chemically chemical
reactions here the eruptions would have
also emitted carbon dioxide causing
global warming okay now when we get Walt
global warming were in danger here right
and when all of the dust clouds and
aerosols washed out of the atmosphere
the excess carbon dioxide would have
remained and the warming would have
proceeded without any mitigating effects
so it's all done by global warming
because that's what isn't them in the
minds of people today so these people
are pending and religion that people
have already bought because the news
talk about you know cats and so on they
they talk about global warming very
often today so that's a volcanism but
you know that's not the only mecca's and
we have better mechanisms than that and
that's the one that guy McPherson
proposes and he gets this from a guy
named Paul Wignall who wrote a paper and
he says that it wasn't the exactly the
volcanoes that killed the animals the
volcanoes did their work but what the
volcanoes did they release the methane
under the sea beds scientists have found
worldwide evidence of a Swift decreasing
of about one percent in the c13 c12
isotope ratio in carbonate rocks from
the end-permian a vast release of
methane might cause significant global
since methane is a very powerful
greenhouse gas strong evidence always
the word evidence into our evidence
suggests that global temperatures
increased by about six degrees near the
equator and now if that doesn't kill all
the Tamils well I don't know what else
you know I mean these guys are really
into chemistry and into using you know
these kinds of effects here's an ox yeah
that's another that's the second-best
anoxia means that we deprive the waters
of oxygen evidence again there were
first word evidence for widespread ocean
anoxia severe deficiency of oxygen and
you Ksenia presence of hydrogen sulfide
is found from the late permian to the
early triassic all these people work on
evidence oh yeah but it's interesting
how they talk about evidence for abcdefg
there's only one of them well they're
they're saying we're we're covering all
the bases we found a little hydrogen
sulfide we found a little and so we're
saying this one killed this guy and this
one kill that so so we could use
explanation a through Z not not that
they all happened because that that's
kind of what you'd expect if if there is
evidence for a B and C yeah there's a B
and C then you think a B and C happened
not a or just B or just see yeah it was
either or not both right but the see ya
know they need all these gases because
first there's evidence of it right they
found it in Iraq or whatever but that's
one issue but then the other issue you
gotta kill this animal with this Kim and
going the other animal with you another
you gotta kill this one run a machine
joining the other gun with a spear and
the other girl with a knife you're
saying you've seen yeah I know and they
make it complicated because it has to be
complicated because they cannot explain
selectivity and the way they explain
selectivities by
bringing different mechanisms
environment this one for this guy this
one for that kind this one for that guy
and they say well this trigger this one
this triggered the other one this
trigger the other one in that's how this
guy died and that's how this guy died so
so they have all these different main
very complex and I'm course if you go to
one of these conferences and they say
well do you know what hydrogen you know
sulfite is and you say well no I never
heard of it and they'll say well you
don't belong here because you wouldn't
understand our presentation in other
words you got to take a college course
to understand a mother nature which is a
very simple woman how mother nature
kills species you know no no I'm seeing
it simple in the sense a you know a
simple meteor hit the earth Saturday
yeah if it kills everyone that's not
what they're saying yes a mystery that
simple his son explosion kills destroy
okay but I got it I think mine is simple
I'm saying eliminate primary production
all the herbivores died and if all the
herbivores died all the carnivores died
that's simple it's I think a baby can
understand that and that's I think how
mother nature works she's a simple woman
she doesn't have all this hydrogen
sulfide methane stuff in her head I
don't think she went to college to take
chemistry she must go nuts with all
these guess so okay so that was the
Permian okay here let me get the other
one you where is it here here's the
hydrogen sulfide because they have one
for Hodges and sulfide especially
biomarker evidence always the word
evidence for enter Abed photosynthesis
by coral bias he green sulfur bacteria
from the late permian into the early
triassic indicates
hydrogen sulfide did up well into
shallow waters so that caused some kind
of killing but I liked the last one
better this one is the best one of all
microbes three lines of evidence always
the word evidence suggests that a genus
of anaerobic methane notch antennae
methanogenic archaea known as methanol
are senior I'm sure mother nature you
know she must suffer as much as these
microbes acquired a new metabolic
pathway via gene transfer at about the
time enabling them to efficiently
metabolize acetate into methane look at
all the other variations here all the
complexity of now this chemical reaction
to kill just to kill beaten to kill
species right that would have led to the
exponential reproduction allowing them
to rapidly consume vast deposits of
organic carbon that had accumulated in
the marine sediment this is what these
people publish you know I'm not kidding
you this this is old because it's
complicated no one understands this over
NFC clapping say man are they smart but
this is this is more or less like
mathematical physics these people are
talking over there and in the eight
billion people out there I have no idea
what these guys are doing these I don't
know how many are there maybe a hundred
thousand at most scientists I mean who's
studying this this night but nonsense
the environmental nonsense let's assume
there's a hundred thousand I'll give you
even a million fine in every country on
the planet let's say there's a million
these people talk amongst themselves and
the public has no idea what these guys
are talking about I mean these guys are
talking about methane at the you know
sulfur and who knows what and acid rain
and and all these different mechanisms
and they're saying there's a the c12 the
c-13 ratio change and what the hell is
all that you know
mother nature's is very simple yeah but
that's your assumption it is my son
cheating there okay it is my assumption
okay so so let me tell you where I stand
and now and I'll just put one piece of
evidence oh yeah I'm gonna put evidence
for the permian okay it's not my
evidence okay this comes from a paper
and it pretty much reflux or synthesizes
what I think this is from Gregg metallic
and he's a permanent buff also and he
says the permian-triassic this is in a
published paper by the way science the
permian-triassic extinction boundary at
251 million years ago was a time of
abrupt decline in both diversity and
provision from provincialism of flores
in south eastern australia and
extinction of glossopteris flora the
glossopteris really occupied all the
southern hemisphere okay early triassic
vegetation was low in diversity and
dominated by Laika pods and bolts lean I
don't know what that is
Conover some kind of conifers the seed
flora Dyke rhodium appeared in the wake
of permian-triassic boundary floral
reorganization what happened was that
the seed fern known as las otras
vanished and the one that came that
replace it was dry Croydon those are two
important markers and again that's what
I use as evidence and as assumptions and
and just to convey the theory not to
convince you but just to convey the
theory to a sub tourist vanished at the
end of the Permian what replaced him was
a whole bunch of plants known as Dyke
rhodium they were other type of seed
ferns and the animals that left they
were established a long-term
relationship with glossopteris and when
the horse after is loved so did the
animals that depended on it and when the
dike Road eum's appeared you know they
replaced them who ate those well the
arcus or the the new animals that
flourished or some other animal but the
point is that you know
when glossopteris left that's when the
mammal-like reptiles the synapsids
that's when they vanished that's what
caused the Permian extinction on land at
least okay and and then again that's my
argument that it's a food mechanism it's
the economic mechanism because that's
what animals manage they're the only
resource that is of any real importance
that animals manage food and so I look
at food food food and only food I'm not
interested in anything else I'm not
saying I don't think any asteroid or
supernova or volcano or any other
changes in the environment causes the
selective extinction of animals
especially specifically that it can kill
chronologically in other words that it
kills only the older species and these
the younger species alive both were
plants and for animals mother nature has
no way of doing that with catastrophic
accidents or catastrophic
ages right you can't do that if you
throw an asteroid on the earth it's
gonna kill everyone it's a you know big
and small alike you can't say well
they'd only killed the big ones and not
the small ones and you can even get away
with that but for sure you cannot say
that look the asteroid hit the earth and
they killed the older species and left
the new species along you need evidence
that it did that that that the older
species died before the new species and
we do have that that evidence is there
it's obvious it's their race to you no
no it's it's there and it's not me no no
listen listen listen the you have the on
the one hand you have what happened at
the end of the Cretaceous you ended up
with very few conifers very few ferns
and you ended up with tons tons of
angiosperms the angiosperms were taken
over the land who ate the angiosperms it
was at the dinosaurs
obviously not they were stuck to the
conifers because they have established
millions of
of relationships with these plans they
grew with the conifers when the plant
with the conifers especially I think the
cycads and the Bennett it tails and the
what is it the cycad like plants when
they disappeared I think that's when the
Triceratops more or less ran into
trouble and that's when the t-rex is
went right after them I think that was
the the sequence and who stood to gain
while the tiny mammals who were not
stuck to the conifers that they ate the
angiosperms and new plants and that's
what you know they flourished and the
same thing happened in the Carboniferous
you know the amphibians died because
they they were stuck to some ancient
plants the like of pods and those were
replaced on a big scale on a massive
scale by the ferns first of all were
there before then but when the ferns
started taking over the land that's when
these guys disappeared and so it's a
food issue that's what animals manage
and that's what keeps them alive
obviously if the food disappears you
know if the gorillas Canty bananas
anymore you know he's going to disappear
and and that's much more logical than
saying you know that some combination of
gases out there in the North Pole
somehow got to African killed the
gorillas you know it's this is what
these people are saying essentially
anyways I just want to make sure that
the people understand that I'm not
saying the same thing as people like
guide McPherson or any of the
environmentalists or climate change errs
or what's the other word
conservationists I'm not saying the same
thing I don't care about the environment
the environment is not part of my theory
my theory is that there's always an
economic collapse in a mass extinction
what disappears is primary production
why because the primary production has
lost its genetic diversity after
millions of years of interbreeding first
and second it suffers it's population
pyramid overturned so that's what's
happening to the plan
the animals don't know about it they
just warns a relationship with these
plants and now suddenly they find
themselves without plants to eat ever
fewer plants to eat the the jungles or
the forests of whatever they ate shrink
I call it the shrinking island and you
have fewer and fewer varieties of
animals and fewer and fewer quantities
of these animals until they died and I'm
talking about the herbivores and of
course when they go you know what dies
next are the carnivores and so what
happens is the ecological pyramid
overturns the the what is called the I
forget the term the you know the three
levels the primary production and when
you call it I forget the term what's the
ecological pyramid essentially but
there's another word for it anyways the
point is that you have the many
carnivores chasing fewer
herbivores chasing even fewer primary
production whatever they ate plants yeah
and so that's the general picture you
know without going into detail so this
which is the normal pyramid turns into
you know this which is the upside down
pyramid you have the many chasing too
few and and that's got nothing to do
with what these people are saying these
people are saying look it's all
chemistry it's you know we we have acid
in the waters we have temperatures
rising on the planet you know none of
that has anything to do with why the
plants disappeared the planets disappear
because of genetic diversity disappeared
they've been inbreeding for who knows
how long and the animals that fords a
relationship with those plants disappear
when the the plants disappear it's an
economic issue
totally and I'm saying that's the same
thing happens to man why does it happen
to man because man produces food
artificially thanks to money and I know
a lot of people here hate me for it and
they're gonna ru until eternity against
me
about money whether money can disappear
and all I can say is we created money
you know we didn't have money before ten
thousand years ago we didn't have money
before the Neolithic there was no money
in the Paleolithic era I'm sorry do two
to wake you up in the Sun the nano-cells
did not use all your bills never
happened never happened
you know hunter-gatherers they don't
trade and I have a hard time convincing
city folks that that is the case people
really think that the nando those traded
beads you know like the Indians did for
Manhattan they think they traded beads
with the with cro-magnon you know for
furs or who knows what never happened
never will and you know just know there
was no trade among hunter-gatherers a
basal hunter-gatherers no such thing in
in nature he who says that simply is is
is an ignorant anthropologist or
paleontologist or whatever they they
have not learned the basics if he really
thinks there was trade and one of those
is John Hawkes he really believes there
was trade between Neanderthals and
humans okay but anyways I just wanted to
point out there is a difference between
guy McPherson me he's an
environmentalist conservationist I'm an
economist when it comes to extinction
okay
its economy that's gonna kill us and
we'll see you tomorrow bye-bye